ahora sí, las voy a compartir pantalla del monroquito
déjame hacer estas cosas
ya
empezando con la clase de hoy, entonces la clase número 10
antes de iniciar la clase pues les voy a comentar algunos puntos del calendario
académico que tengamos y les he comentado en la parte del grupo para que tener en cuenta
ya, de mi monroquito voy a mocharles esa parte
ya
en nuestra clase número 10 la programación de todas las clases son total 12 clases
perdón 22 clases, son total 22 clases de las cuales 4 de esas clases son
netamente exposición de sus trabajos de las cuales como estamos viendo ahorita
que son un promedio de 20 alumnos de los 32 que son de los 20 pongámosle que
durante cuatro clases 5 van a exponer 5 grupos, de los 5 personas van a exponer
ya entonces esas fechas van a ser las siguientes, vuelvo a repetirles la cantidad de clases son
22 clases, ya hoy estamos en la clase número 10 y desde el sábado estaríamos en clase número 11
pero en este caso vamos a fijar algunos horarios para lo cual voy a habilitar mi word y ahí les
voy a, se los voy a notar para que lo tengan también porque es lo que es subir a plataforma y van a
tener las fechas estimadas y las fechas en las cuales nosotros vamos a terminar la
clase en este caso, ya, de monroquito voy a mocharles sobre esta parte cita
listo, ya voy a admitir alguien más ahora si, entonces hablaremos un cachito de los cronogramas
entonces desde nuestro programa voy a colocar esta parte
ya de un cachito voy a
clicar esta cosa
y anotaremos bien antes, les voy a esperar los demás que vean entrando mientras tanto, ya
entonces voy a insertar a ver
ya, entonces lo siguiente, oye la clase número 10, 4 de junio y a nos quedaría todo esto, todo ese
punto voy a eliminar esta parte, vamos a estimar fechas, ya vamos a estimar fechas para sus diferentes
actividades que se va a tener, nos quedaría estos
ahí de todo junio, ya, entonces voy a anotarme algunos puntitos, ya, antes de iniciar, ya,
entonces, esta es nuestra clase número
actualmente la 10, la 11, 12, 13, 14, 15, 16, 17, del 17 más o menos, esto hace nos quedarse 18,
19, 20, 21 y 22, ya 22 clases, de las cuales estas que voy a colocar en amarillo
son netamente para ustedes de defensa, ya, pero les había comentado que vamos a
minimizar el tiempo, es decir que solamente vamos a hasta el 9, les había comentado,
hasta el 9, entonces ustedes estarían defendiendo el 27, el 2, el 4 y el 9 de sus proyectos, ya,
en otras palabras nos quedan solamente 6 clases, ya, obviamente aparte muy bien y ahí va a terminar
su proyecto, el día 11, ustedes ya tienen que presentar sus píxanes, de enbajada y el 16
hasta el 23 que tienen tiempo, ya, así que en base eso vayan cronometrándose y eso es nuestro final de
clases, ya, listo, si está bien, porque a ver, 2, 4, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 20, si, esto más bien chicos,
si, eso, eso vayan anotándose, bueno, les voy a pasar esto, por si acaso esa es la color amarilla,
los que acaban de entrar, es netamente para la parte de exposiciones, de aquí el 13, voy a darles
la lista de quienes oficialmente están inscritos, porque son 32, los que son 32 solamente asisten 20
y solamente voy a repartir entre los 20, ya, y esa parte van ahí a armándose, el 13 voy a
llamar a la lista oficial para que que personas van a asistir, el 27, el 2, el 4 y el 9, ya,
es independientemente, pues de acaso esta parte no es necesaria que nos en todo, solamente los que
están asignados en esas fechas, nada más, ya, así que empezaremos de nuevo chicos, ahora si,
6 class nos queda aparte de hoy día, ya, así que voy a tratar de hacerlo más
completo posible, quizás haya un módulo 2, pero el módulo 2 no creo que lo llevemos este
en este curso, el módulo es netamente de pbps y abds, así que eso es cuando se hace producción
a nivel un poquito más avanzado, eso va a ver el módulo 2 lo más probable, ya, pero no sé si,
no me encoge ahorita, todavía los iba a ver el módulo 2, módulo 2 y ya, ya, haremos de una vez
un... ¿Y Jef? ¿De culpa de? Una preguntita. Claro, ¿Qué pasó? ¿Cómo está, Vanessa? ¿Querías
hacer una cosa surta, Jef? Tengo un problemita con mi N8N, quería por ejemplo entrar hace,
hace, o sea, el día de ayer, pero me sale que la versión que tengo, o sea, que ya, o sea, la parte
gratuita que tengo ya no, ya no está, ya, es como que intenté meter, echar mi, ingresar a mis flujos
de trabajo y me salía que ya estaba como que, caucado o expirado y ya no me dejan entrar, entonces,
¿Qué puedo hacer aquí? ¿Tengo que hacerlo de nuevo todo el flujo que venía haciendo? ¿O no necesito
recuperarlo?
En sí, has debido de crearlo mediante por usuario en Internet porque el N8N es gratuito, el local
host, es decir, no tienes que pagar nada y debería haberse creado, no debería haberte dicho que tienes
flujos limitados en tus palabras, eso habría que volver a instalarlo de cero y volverlo a generar,
ya, porque eso tienes que ser lo mediante sin Internet. Una vez que lo descargas, lo desactivas
el Internet y lo directamente lo ejecutas sin Internet, pero y cuando ya te bote lo que es la
parte de lo que es el usuario que el contraseña, te va a botear y crear el usuario contraseño,
pero que tiene que decirte local host, si dice otra cosa es porque lo has creado de manera en línea.
En la página de N8N.
Sí, y no hay que hacer eso porque si es que el mismo usuario, o sea, hay otro problema también,
si es que el mismo usuario es repetido con el mismo usuario que te has creado localmente y el mismo
usuario has creado de manera en N8N, la plataforma oficial, te va a denegar todo.
Pues esa parte no, sería que lo instalas de nuevo y justamente cuando ya lo tengas acá,
si instalado lo desactivas en Internet. Esto cuando ya te bote la página.
Pero sería solamente en este caso digamos que yo me desinstale solamente en N8N,
o sea el Note, el Docker, todo ya lo mantengo.
Eso es normal, el Note y eso es un trabajo interno.
En N8N, listo? Si necesitan ahí de ahora, los voy a mandar igual a un videito para que
puden hacer ese proceso. ¿Listo? Valeria quería hablar. ¿Qué pasa, Vale?
Si, era un aspecto para aconsejarle a Gabriel no hay que yo tuve esa misma situación,
hacer un par de semanas y en realidad este amigo me hiciera error pero volví a crear,
obviamente cambié los usuarios con otro correo en mis casos y pero me lo caljó
todos mis flujos de trabajo ya cuando ingresé con esa nueva cuenta, se mantenía,
no se había borrado ninguno y desde ahí ya no tuvo problema.
Exacto, gracias Valeria, si el mismo aspecto, gracias Valeria.
Ahora si vayan activando mientras tanto son hecho en N, haremos la parte de, voy a eso ahora con otra
de Inteligencia Artificial y con eso creo que los vas a soltar mucho más barato y más gratuito.
A ver, vamos a intentar con eso hoy día para que no tengan problemas a FotoLog,
ven inicializándolo, ven un poquito chicos.
Listo, ahora si, mi Lisco aquí tengo un perrito,
mi de loco es que se encha mi oficina de la nada, golpeando todo.
Ahora si, listo, empezaremos entonces.
Ya los comparto esta parte, listo.
Crearemos un nuevo workflow, ya.
Listo de este workflow, voy a crear los siguientes aspectos.
Antes de eso, antes, antes, antes, pueden abrirse Canvas,
Val, que es gratuito, si tienen el Canvas Premium Super o ahorita mismo creense
cualquier PDF relacionado con su negocio. O sea ahorita no quiero que lo aprendan en su negocio,
sino que un ejemplo. Yo voy a usar ahorita venta de laptops, ya, venta de laptops,
si voy a crear un Canvas, que es netamente venta de laptops,
o sea, aunque tres marcas pueden crearse, ya ahorita vamos a hacer esta parte.
Lo siguiente, me voy a entrar acá, ahora hay otro punto,
y esto debería aprovecharlo porque está barato.
Sienten a DeepSick Platform, ya, Platform.
En DeepSick Platform es donde pueden adquirir ustedes sus apiquis, ya,
igual, cualquier tipo de LMS. El idéntico que el OpenAI, ya,
solamente fíjense que en este caso, hoy día lo he comprado para hacer la prueba,
como realmente era. Y miren, viene, les comento que se puede comprar desde dos dólares,
los pricing. Voy a ir marcar los modelos y los modelos de vota por dos dólares las últimas
versiones, es el Flask y el B4 Pro por lo. Y lo bueno que cuando se compran con dos dólares,
pasa lo siguiente. Me voy a ir acá, por ejemplo, hecho en los case, miren acá dice,
he utilizado los dos, el Flask y el Pro para ver y fíjense, cuando utilizo las últimas versiones
de los modelos de IA de DeepSick, me cobra 0.01 dólares por token, pero este token es bien
complejo, así que yo le daría un buen crédito de aspecto, ya, pero tiene una parte que es gratuita,
que es el DeepSick Chat o DeepSick Resoner, o sea, es un DeepSick que piensa con un modelo básico,
pero te responde rápidamente y no me cobra nada. Les cobra 0.000001 dólares por token,
es decir, es como si en vez de, ahorita compre un usuario de un millón de tokens,
pero cuando trabajo con DeepSick Chat y DeepSick Resoner, me da más que todo hasta 5 millones
de tokens. Imagínense, es más barato. Y la cuenta oficial me permite pagarlo desde dos dólares,
pueden subirlo a 5, a 20, a lo que ustedes quieran, pero es mucho más barato. Ya, eso yo los recomiendo
que se compre, mire, acá 2 dólares, 5, y este es más su, este me ha cobrado más, IVA,
pero ahí está, pueden trabajarlos. Y es más fácil, me bota el tiro y funciona,
por eso voy a salir y los voy a pasar el token. Así que voy a abrirme un instant
blog de notas. Y lo bueno es que les acepta cualquier banco, así que no hay problema.
Deben un coche, los voy a dar una API, la API que está utilizando los voy a dar mejor en esto.
Igual API key se crean un nuevo API y igual es lo otro, si es API, se lo trabajan con su sistema.
Ya, es más rápido, incluso que el mismo OpenAI. Ahora si me voy a ir acá y haremos el proceso de
trabajo, los estoy pasando ahorita la API key, DeepSick, a la mensajería de Meet, ya, ahí les
he pasado por eso. Van a copiar desde el SK y eso, ya, ya los he enviado. Así continuaremos con
esta fase del proceso. Voy a trabajar casi lo mismo. Hoy quizás la clase va a ser un poquito,
lo voy a dividir en dos clases, lo que vamos a hacer hoy día. La siguiente clase ya voy a aplicar
WhatsApps, Evolutions, voy a aplicar a DPTFs, porque no sé si se han dado cuenta. Cuando alguna
empresa me envía, digamos, a mi WhatsApp, a mi correo, sus publicidades, qué me envía su catálogo,
me envía su QR y me envía, a veces, todo su temario, ¿no? Entonces yo vamos a integrar algo de
DPTFs que están exados sus sistemas. Y vamos a ver que con este modelo de DeepSick es más fácil
de hacer. Ya, a ver, vamos a venir acá y vamos a hacer con OpenAI, o si lo tienen con OpenAI,
pueden trabajar de la misma manera. Vamos a ir a One Force Submission, ya saben que esto lo pueden
trabajar con un webhook, pero mientras tanto, para hacer pruebas antes de meter la webhooks,
vamos a trabajar con eso, ¿no? Así que se saca One Force Submission, luego de esto se van a sacar
esto siguiente, ¿vienen acá? Ya saben, siempre tenemos que capturar los datos, así que voy a
colocar a DPTFs y escribo acá a DPTFs y se sacan este. Lo voy a sacar y listo, ya se ha conectado
automáticamente. Una vez que saque ese, voy a sacar el DeepSick. Ya, DeepSick.
El DeepSick aquí dice DeepSick Chat Model, ya, ese es el modelo gratuito que ya tiene DeepSick. No
es tan gratuito que digamos, pero eso es medio gratuito, ¿verdad? Son esos 100%. Listo. Y les va a
votar esto, ya. Así. Ahí está. Este yo lo voy a eliminar y lo voy a conectar de manera directa
este con este, ya, porque ahí solo me estoy haciendo pruebas con el otro hook. Ya, una vez que tengan esto,
analizaremos algunos puntos, ya. Así que en la parte de One Force Submission, me voy a crear
algunas entidades, ya. Los voy esperando hasta ahí para que lo vean teniendo. Vean pensando en un
tipo de negocio hoy día, alterno a sus proyectos y ahorita vamos a crear algunos puntos de para
nuestro PDF, ya. Para que también pueda obtener datos de ahí e echarse a los mismos desde el PDF.
Así que para esa parte los voy dejando tiempito y yo voy a estar habilitando mi
mi camba, ya. Ya.
Ahí los voy a dejar un cacho, voy a encocaditarlo y demás.
Y abranse un camba o abranse cualquier, aunque un WordSync no tiene, no quieren
utilizar camba porque todos tenemos cambas y que, pero es que no quieren trabajar con solamente
directamente, vayan copiándose y eso me van a enviar hoy día como su tal trabajo, ya.
Esta clase nueva es tan compleja, pero va a ser más trabajable. Así que démenme un ratito,
voy a colocar lo siguiente. Voy a crear mi mensaje tanto. Ya. A ver, los indico esa parte.
Si es que algunos de esos nuevos utilizan el TVCamba, viene acá y digamos van a colocar
el que crear. Y en este caso van a colocar un documento A4. Ya. Un documento, si no, no hay problema.
A un doc digital, listo? En este caso voy a hacer un doc digital porque no se tan vacío y ya tenga
algunas plantillas. Ya. Vayan haciendo eso igual para que los vaya igual trabajando. Ya.
Porque me van en el patafono van a subir su PDF más trabajado. Obviamente,
háganlo lo más sencillo posible, pero que sea adecuado. A ver, aquí voy a escribir
un tienda de laptops. Tienda de laptops. Listo. No voy a generar porque sé que no debe haber.
Ya. Ustedes hagan lo normal. Yo tengo el Pro. Pues que lo puedo generar, pero si
usted no tiene el Pro, pueden copiar si pegar sus imágenes. No hay ni. Ya. Aquí me he generado
algunos. Bueno, aquí me dice tienda de laptops. Ya. Tipo de laptops. Esta. Ultra box. Gaming.
Estudiantes. Ya me he generado todo. Ya. La vea si entonces genera. Mén. Un catálogo.
Con imágenes o con productos. De modelos de laptops.
Laptops con imagen.
Con imagen de la con imagen y precio.
Listo. No voy a ser generar.
A ver, veremos que me bota.
Bueno, aquí me he dado una perspectiva. Vamos a ver si lo ha hecho todo.
A ver, lo voy a reemplazar.
Y listo.
No, yo no me he generado bastantes.
No me he generado los.
Los catálogos que necesito, pero lo puedo anexar este con este. Ya lo vamos a anexar este con
este eliminar y voy a ver las páginas de esto.
No lo sé. Listo. Y voy a hacer los. No sé si esto es viste de cuadrícula.
Y voy a colocar a ver. Vayan haciendo estas mientras tanto.
Y me voy a dejarlo así. Voy a añadirme algunas imágenes para que la I ya me entienda y lo
haga. Así que aquí voy a colocar laptop extreme.
Extreme.
Listo. Vayan armándose. Aunque tres imágenes. No hay problema si cada una o dos.
Ya me voy a inventar esa. Listo.
Ay, lo voy a acomodar. Ya.
Otra más acá. Aquí dice un apto profesional.
Listo. Ay, hasta está medio. Qué interesante.
Listo. Lo copio y lo voy a pegar acá.
Listo.
Por otro. Va a ver. Unas dos más voy a hacer. Ya. Vayan haciendo ustedes igual.
Depende de qué quieren hacer su sistema.
Otra boca de light. Es esto.
Ya. Me dio que esta está buena la imagen. Ya. Listo.
Vamos a ir listo.
Y una ultimita que la esencia.
600 dólares. No conozco esos.
Estas laptops.
Hmm.
Interesante.
Ya.
Listo. Ya. Hací armándose bonito.
Lo más sintetizado posible. Ya.
Ya. Ahora si no tienen canvas, díganle a a Gemini que se los
hago. Gemini tiene un potente con nano banana.
Lo ve. Así que con nano banana se pueden generar su catálogo de
ustedes. Ya. Lo voy a eliminar esto y eso voy a dejarlo y tal
cual lo que quiera. Productos al me inventaré la parte de del
nombre de la empresa.
A ver que lo voy a modificando ahí.
Y listo.
Vamos a colocarle producto laptop center. No se va a inventar.
Laptops.
Pssss.
Center.
Listo. Voy a colocar modelos.
Modelos.
Bueno, voy a ultimos.
Modelos. No se va a inventar.
Mira.
Voy a decirlo en Bolivia para este. Pero tal o algo específico.
Listo. Lo guardamos.
Y ya está. Ya.
Hmm. Tengo cuatro productos. Listo.
Esto voy a hacer lo siguiente. Voy a compartirlo.
Y lo exportaré en formato PDF.
Descargar PDF.
Vamos a cargarlo ahí.
Y listo. Ya vamos a descregar.
Yo.
Y ya les voy dando tiempo.
Para que ustedes más saben.
Listo. Emicos ya descargado. Mientras vos te ven haciendo unos dos,
tres, cuatro productos mínimo, tres chicos para que no les generen
falsas expectativas la idea.
Así que.
Mínimo creanse en unos tres o cuatro productos.
Yo. En mi caso ya se ha descargado.
Listo.
Ahora voy a irme directamente a lo que hace a lo.
Y voy a abrirme en tanto sus trabajos.
Pues abranse un word para el trabajo número 7.
Y ya saben que colocar clase número 10. Tantas, tantas, tantas.
Y me voy a ejecutar.
Ya ahorita os voy a decir qué capturas voy a necesitar hoy día.
Hoy en entro poquito son 16 de los 20.
Ya me estaba en su feriado.
Ya ahora sí.
Van a colocar clase número 10.
Nombre completo.
Van a colocar ahí y van a colocar la fecha de.
Me ha hecho.
Y listo.
Ya nada más.
Y vamos a hacer la siguiente captura.
Listo.
Pensé que voy a colocar.
Evaluación.
Contínua.
Continua número 7.
Ya captura.
Y ya captura.
Y ya captura 1.
Van a colocar lo que es el modelo de negocio.
Por si.
En este caso, netamente estoy haciendo un catálogo.
Y ya.
Listo.
Entonces esta parte para no confundir mi demás.
Lo voy a copiar y pegar varios.
Vamos a hacer unas 5 capturitas hoy día.
Ya que la siguiente vamos a completarlo.
Y creo que está el.
Voy a dar un cacho.
Corregirlo.
Ya.
Y ahora sí.
Ahora sí lo procesaremos.
Listo.
Y listo.
Ya.
Esto no me interesa todo bien.
Listo.
En el modelo de negocio de acá.
Me van a hacer la primera captura de quién.
De su.
Pdf.
Ya.
En este caso pueden hacer captura de dónde están trabajando.
O la descarga que les ha originado.
Eso pueden sacarlo su pdf.
Su screen de pantalla.
Listo.
No hay problema.
Ya lo tienen ahí.
Y listo.
Ese va a ser el primero.
Está cargando.
Listo.
Ese es su primera captura.
Es el modelo de su negocio.
Y van a colocar metálico al esterco al carro.
Listo.
En formato pdf.
Luego lo descargen.
Hasta ahí les voy dando un tiempo.
En los tres minutitos.
Cuatro minutitos.
Hagan que la ya se los haga.
Y solamente se diseñan las imágenes.
Nada más.
Ya.
Ahí les voy a dar un comentario.
Y abranse paralelamente.
Un.
El drive donde están trabajando con sus app.
Con sus.
Credenciales.
Es.
Esa cuenta.
Abranse.
Yo siempre lo hago aparte por.
Por muchas cosas.
Porque.
Mezclar cosas de negocio.
Y.
Porque.
Mezclar cosas de negocio.
Y mezclar cosas de nuestro diario.
Vivir.
No es.
Lo más recomendable.
Así que me voy a abrir.
Estaba trabajando con el.
En el 8n.
Y.
Crense un.
En su.
Drive.
Créense netamente.
Ustedes.
Una.
Carpetica.
Que diga.
No sé.
Cualquier nombre.
Yo lo estoy colocando.
Archivos.
Dentro de.
En el archivo estoy creando.
Pdf.
Y dentro de pdf.
Voy a.
Aláres el.
El.
Pdf.
Que me he creado.
Ya.
Ahí.
Pienso.
Viendo.
Yo lo voy a colocar a mi.
Pdf.
Otro nombre.
De nuevo.
Lo titulé.
Colocalón.
Catálogo.
Productos.
Estar.
Laptops.
20.
26.
Digo.
O sea.
La mayoría.
Cuando.
Cuando vende sus productos.
Siempre la coloqué sus.
Fechas.
No.
No estoy subiendo.
Ahora fíjense lo que estoy haciendo acá.
Cuando ustedes van a subir.
Cualquier tipo de catálogos.
Pdf.
O.
Lo que ustedes quieran realizar.
Siempre van a trabajar con.
Barra baja.
Para los espacios.
O bien.
Directamente.
Háselo todo junto.
Ya.
Por el.
Este caso.
Porque veces la.
Interpeta mal.
Y.
No.
No responda.
No lo complementa.
Así que siempre es bueno trabajar sin.
Sin espacios.
Sin.
En vez de espacios.
Barra baja.
Ya.
Pueden hacer guiones.
Pero más recomendables.
Barra baja.
De catálogo.
Laptop.
20.
26.
Listo.
Así lo van a hacer.
Páxia más entendible.
Ya.
Esa base su segunda captura.
Ya crean sus.
En su.
Unidad.
Sus archivos.
De ahí.
En su.
No sé.
N8N.
Pueden colocar.
N8N producto.
No sé.
Cree.
Conveniente.
Vayan haciéndolo.
Ya.
Les doy hasta unos 5.
Miluticos.
Y ya voy a empezar.
Hacer lo siguiente.
Ya.
A partir de.
Esta clase.
La siguiente.
Es que nos resta las 6.
Casi.
Se nos resta.
Netamente.
Chicos.
Vayan.
Me hayan.
Y.
Los.
Pede.
Enviar van a ser.
Directamente.
En clase.
O hasta.
Media noche de esa misma clase.
Esto.
Por cuáles cuestiones nos están pidiendo notas.
urgentemente.
Así que.
Yo tengo que.
Subirlo.
Inmediatamente.
Pero.
Los voy a tratar de hablar.
Los voy a tratar de dar.
La lista oficial.
Lo voy a pedir a.
Al encargado.
La lista oficial.
Para.
Ya.
Ver.
Quienes realmente están y no están.
Porque son 32 personas.
Son las de los cuales solamente.
Estan 20.
Así que.
Eso parte voy a analizar.
Internamente.
Ya.
Hay.
Todos los.
Próxicos.
Hasta.
Y sin costes.
Y 6 tienen.
Las 2 6 para.
Crear su catálogo.
Y.
Ya.
Estar un minuto y co.
Empezamos.
¿Sí?
Sí.
No.
Yo.
Ya, listo, 16.
Ahora uno siguiente.
Ya una vez que ya hayan subido su catálogo,
ya ya en este caso también trabajado mediante su aspecto,
de Warflow vamos a hacer lo siguiente.
Generalmente acá lo que les acabo de enviar a ustedes es el,
el apiqui, hagan doble clic acá.
Ahora aquí dice,
DeepSeqAccount van a crearse una credencial, ya.
En esa credencial si se dan cuenta es mucho más sencillo,
solamente me pide la apiqui, ya.
Ya lo voy a copiar mi apiqui,
que les he enviado igual a ustedes,
y peganlo ahí, ya, y lo guardo.
Y aquí les dice,
Credential successfully created,
y hay inside your personal space.
Esa parte lo van a igual sacar como su tercera captura.
Ya, listo.
Esa parte ya tiene que estar directamente en la sal.
Voy a irme entonces a mi world,
no sé porque he abierto tantos worlds en mi rato.
No sé qué ha pasado, pero ya,
mismo es nuestro, vamos a trabajar acá.
Captura 3, conexión,
a DeepSeq.
Listo.
La de nosotros, crees que se voy a hacer con CloudCode?
CloudCode van a ver que es monstruo.
Es un monstruo, literal, es un monstruo, tiene todo,
hasta tiene sentimientos, creo.
Listo, bueno, lo hago.
Y por ejemplo, ahorita lo que son las LLMS de OpenAI,
me sirven más que todo para hacer charlos,
lo que hemos hecho anteriormente.
Las de DeepSeq son más numéricas,
o sea, son más matemáticas.
Las de CloudCode son más de interfaces.
Y esos tres, si se combinan,
nuestros agentes hacen lo que quieran ustedes.
Pueden incluso meter a otros agentes en uno mismo.
Si quieren hacer un proyecto de automatización,
por ejemplo, para el Instituto Balceiro,
les voy a mostrar cómo trabajar el Instituto Balceiro
en NSTOS, en NEOGENER.
No sé si han escuchado el Instituto Balceiro, pero...
Es uno de las universidades más potentes
a nivel mundial en física nuclear y sistemas
que se llama Producción en Inteligencia Artificiales
y Ciencias Informáticas,
que netamente el que es su líder se llama Maldacen.
Maldacen es uno de los instants de nuestro...
Bueno, de nuestra época mostrador.
Y aquí tienen niveles impresionantes.
Su sistema está hecho con N8N.
Y sus exámenes se han hecho con N8N.
Y esto está enlazado con MIT de Estados Unidos
y van a ver cómo su flujo.
Ya no me acuerdo de dónde estaban sus flujos, pero lo van a ver.
Ellos, por ejemplo, hacen N8N y automateccion
con sistemas para el desarrollo de física termo nuclear
y nuclear para sistemas cuánticos.
Ellos lo trabajan con siete agentes.
Netamente trabajan con agentes, en este caso,
de IA contemporánea, IA moderna, IA híbrida.
O sea, CloudCode es la IA híbrida.
IA y Aia se todo.
CloudCode lo maneja y lo toma a DeepSync
y DeepSync lo toma a OpenAI
y los tres ya trabajan con tres agentes potentes a nivel cuántico.
Ellos Maldacen, el hace sus sistemas.
Si creen leerle a él, es interesante.
Esta tiene más de 5.500 artículos científicos publicados
en solamente 10 años.
Es la nivel potencia.
Ya, ahora seguiremos al otro punto, donde estamos
volviendo al medio de la asunta.
Ahora acá, por ejemplo,
se actualizan los repositories V4 y la Pro, que son las últimas.
Ya no les recomiendo eso. Déjenlo por defecto ahí.
Aunque les salga a warning
porque van a tener problemas
en que les va a cobrar.
No va a ser tal cuál es el cobro,
pero así les va a terminar el token.
Así que déjenlo por defecto.
Ahora, en añadir opciones,
pueden añadir paramétricas y métricas,
pero no es necesario por el momento.
Hoy te vamos a ver cómo se trabajan estos modelitos.
Pero lo voy a hacer.
Y voy a irme directamente a OneFourSubmission.
En OneFourSubmission, voy a hacer lo que necesito.
Es decir, voy a crear mi empresa.
Esto ya sabemos, ¿o sí?
Voy a colocar aquí el LabCenter.
Y aquí voy a colocar en este caso,
sistemas, venta,
venta e importación
de laptops.
Ya, listo.
Luego, aquí voy a añadir, ¿qué quiero capturar del cliente?
Ya lo sabéis, yo no me trabajo muchas veces,
así que no hago mucho problema.
Voy a utilizar tres variables,
aún más, esperando que no se lo tan largo.
Text simple, que es el requerido.
Recall file, el requerido.
Vamos a añadir en este caso, su Gmail.
Correo.
Tipo Gmail.
Y vamos a colocar directamente el requerido.
Listo.
Y obviamente, el mensaje, ¿no?
Tipo TextOrea.
Y directamente atributos,
que es también un campo publicatorio.
Ya.
Nada más. Eso sería todo.
Ahora, aquí voy a colocar la Oceans.
App n8, no atributos.
Y ahora voy a descontinuar.
Y listo.
Hasta ahí.
Lo ejecutaremos.
Ejecutamos y voy a
realizar algunas cosas.
Milton,
Peño Blanco, listo.
Ahora voy, me olvido mi
mi correo de este.
Voy a copiarme
y voy a jugar loca.
Buenas noches
que quisiera
saber qué productos
tienen
a la venta.
Listo.
Lo voy a subir.
Y buena vez que lo he subido.
Ya lo voy a
pinear acá.
A veces no se ve mucho ahí.
Pueden esto un poquito llevarlo a este lado.
Minimizarlo un poquito.
Y listo.
Ahora se van a colocar el pin de ahí.
Hacen el pin de ira.
Y directamente ya.
Esto va a ser cuarto
o tercero.
Ya.
Ahí que tenga.
Ya. Voy a venir acá.
Entonces.
El número de captura es
cuatro. Ya. Creo que es cuatro.
Si estamos bien, ¿no?
Es cuatro. Ya.
Listo.
Captura número cuatro.
Voy a colocar conexión.
No. En este caso, si conexionado.
On from
Submission.
Listo.
Voy a copiarme esto. Voy a hacer la captura cinco.
A partir de acá si va a ser un poquito más
especial.
Pero van a tomarle un comentario.
Esto.
Una vez que ya lo tenga en pin.
Vamos a ver el flujo.
Ahora esta parte voy a capturar los datos.
No estoy ya sabiendo.
Estoy ya hemos hecho varias veces. Así que doble.
Doble clic.
Voy a dejar cada uno de esto.
El nombre.
El correo.
Y el mensaje.
Listo.
Listo. Ya esta.
Entonces, se va a hacer mi segundo.
Escribe.
Pero mi quinto.
Voy a venir acá y ver si configuración.
Edit.
Files.
Configuración.
Del.
Edit.
Files.
Listo.
Ya esta. Ya lo tenemos ahí.
Ahora si.
Una vez que tengamos ese proceso.
Voy a.
Continuar con lo siguiente.
Por adentro de acá.
Este es el que me va a generar un montón de problemas.
Ya.
Hago primeramente clic.
Vuelvo a repetir.
Me voy a basic.
El lm.
Hago doble clic.
Ya.
Aquí es un poquito medio.
Este.
Como les explico.
Un poquito interesante.
Ya la ves.
Especial esta cuartecita.
Lo que voy a hacer lo siguiente.
Aquí dice.
Para esta parte.
Vamos a tomar en cuenta algunos puntos.
Más.
Que tenemos que aplicar acá.
Por ejemplo lo siguiente.
Vean.
Aquí dice.
Esta parte.
Me estás diciendo que los nodos directamente.
Ya pueden ser conectados.
Ya.
Esto no es bueno.
Porque antes se tiene que definir algunos puntos.
Algunas expresiones.
Definir.
Ya.
Vamos a trabajar.
Aquí.
Me dice.
Hola.
Aquí voy a colocar la bienvenida al usuario.
Ya es decir.
Puedo colocar directamente.
Bienvenido.
A la.
La.
Listo.
Ahora acá.
Me dice.
Ya.
Y dentro de estos.
Y aquí dice.
Añadimos.
Y esta parte si se dan cuenta.
Es la misma que se ha utilizado anteriormente.
En qué.
En opinión.
Es lo mismo.
Solamente acá.
Le voy a darle prompt.
Necesario.
Porque estoy eligiendo.
Están los tres roles que los he indicado.
Voy a hacer.
Y voy a hacer.
Y.
Eres.
Asistente.
Comercia.
Ya.
En este caso responde.
De forma.
Lara.
Y profesional.
Y.
A este usuario.
Van a colocar dos puntos.
Y ahorita lo vamos a preguer eso.
Voy a irme hacia abajo.
Voy a hacer.
Envía.
El mensaje.
Respuesta.
En formato.
HTML.
Y.
CSS.
Esto.
Voy a cerrar esta parte.
Y acá.
Por si acaso van a jalar este.
El nombre del usuario.
No sé dónde estará.
Voy a modificar.
Yo.
En esto lo voy a cortar y pegar donde quiero que esté.
Ahí.
Listo.
Nada más.
Y.
Una vez que lo cierren.
Directamente voy a añadir otro prompt.
Este prompt.
Pero va a ser del usuario.
Y el mensaje que se va a adaptar.
Pues vosotros el mensaje.
Quiere estar diciendo.
Listo.
Nada más.
Hasta ahí lo tienen.
Para hacer la siguiente fase.
Yo.
Qué más.
Ahora acá por ejemplo.
Si hacemos aquí.
Dice.
Podemos aumentar algunos tipos de.
Pensamientos.
Pero luego lo vamos a hacer.
Pueden ejecutar.
Lo ejecutan.
Aquí debería darme el formato.
HTML.
Y demás.
Yo.
Lo esperamos.
Porque va a tardar un poco en cranear al principio.
Ya saben.
Pero es un poquito más veloz que el.
Open ahí.
Bien.
Ahora como ya me ha dado.
Algunas respuestas.
Podemos verlo en forma de tabla.
Y está todo lo que me ha respondido.
Y aquí también me da un formato.
Y ahí me dice todo lo que me está respondiendo.
Ya.
Directamente lo voy a cerrar.
Y listo.
Ya tengo las conexiones necesarias.
Posteriora eso.
Puedo yo llevarlo a mensaje.
Así que voy a irme a mi.
Gmail.
Y voy a enviarme un send.
Message.
Gmail.
Send.
Message.
Hago clic.
Y justamente ya lo tengo acá capturado.
Y aquí me dice el conectado automáticamente.
Esta parte.
Ya lo saben ustedes.
Ya hago doble clic.
Aquí les vaya a decir cuáles su cuenta.
Ya en la sala su credencial.
De lo que es la.
La parte de Gmail.
Y acá.
Voy a sacar siempre.
Voy a hacerlo de edit files.
Y voy a sacar siempre correo ahí.
Nunca.
De.
Subject.
Que me va a decir bienvenido.
O.
Lapsenter.
Listo.
Y aquí el mensaje.
Va a ser la el mensaje.
Que ha hecho la lla.
El text.
Hago clic.
Listo.
Ya lo ejecutamos.
Ahora acá.
Aquí es algo interesante.
Hoy estamos hacerlo con veces.
Y bueno a ver qué pasa.
Lo ejecuto.
Y ya se enviado.
No.
Listo.
Voy a irme a mi.
Mi unidad.
Perdón.
Esto no es mi correo.
Es mi droid.
Voy a irme a mi correo.
Y vamos a ver.
Que sea.
821 para que estén listos.
Ahí está.
Me da lapsenter.
Me da el catálogo.
Y me da todo.
No lo ha hecho tan estético.
Pero.
Aquí ya me está generando hasta un catálogo.
Disponible.
Y ahí es donde tengo que anexarlo mis PDF.
Pero ahí pueden ver.
Funciona.
10 mucho más barato.
Y a ver. Ustedes vayan haciéndolo.
Y vamos a ver.
Cuánto ha consumido en créditos.
Por qué ahorita estoy haciendo con el apps normal.
Pero.
Vamos a irnos acá.
A Dipsy platform.
Voy a irme a mi.
A Piquí.
Y voy a ver a caminar mi token.
Ahí está.
Cero me sigue cobrando.
Cero.
Porque estoy utilizando chat normal.
Pues no me ha hecho algo tan estético.
Ahora te puedo utilizar el flash.
Voy a ver.
Aquí voy a ver si están trabajando ustedes.
Porque esto me tiene que generar varios.
Penpoints.
Voy a actualizar.
Vamos a ver si están trabajando.
Ya.
Ya hay dos personas.
Pero nadie más.
Dos requests.
Aquí están.
259 tokens.
Esos míos.
A ver una vez más.
Vamos a ver si están trabajando.
Ahí más.
Si están haciendo.
Está bien.
2578 tokens.
A ver una vez más.
Ahí se ha quedado.
Aquí hay otros más.
Está bien.
Ya están trabajando.
Pero si están en cuenta no gasta.
Ahora voy a utilizar el modo.
Modo.
Modo monstruo.
Ya.
Aquí directamente.
Van a cambiarlo.
Ah.
Perdón.
Esta parte chicos.
El modelo.
Veas.
Este modelito.
Esa es la parte que se hace.
Como se escribe.
Porque desaparece cuando eligen.
De memoria.
Deep seek.
Espacio chat.
Y los llevan a elegir.
Voy a utilizar el flash.
El pro.
Vamos a ver qué tal con el pro.
Lo voy a hacer.
Y lo voy a ejecutar directamente.
Lo ejecutamos.
Vamos a ver cuál es su cambio.
Pero hay que hacer varios entrenamientos.
Para que mejore.
Vamos a ver si la primera da.
No he hecho el flash.
El pro me ha dado buena interfaz.
Vamos a ver si el otro no da.
Pero van a ver que con este me va a cobrar dinero.
Pero vamos a ver si realmente es.
Que se llama.
Voy a ver.
Voy a ver acá.
Vamos a ver.
Este lapsen me envía otro.
Ya.
Me dio que ha mejorado.
Algo.
No es lo que espero.
Pero obviamente le doy un pro bastante básico.
Debería darle un pro más.
Más específico.
Y además bien.
Como yo no le he hecho un pro directamente.
Que le he delimitado.
Me ha hecho cualquier pro.
Por eso le quedan los pro.
Porque aquí debería decirle.
En mi prompt.
Trabajame en este caso.
De tal mente con qué.
Ya.
Eres un estente comercial.
De venta de laptops.
Laptops.
En todos los modelos.
Y además.
Hacemos.
Importaciones.
Como nos ubicamos.
En la paz.
Cocha.
Y Santa Cruz.
Listo.
Ya está.
Eso debería de hacer.
Aquí si tienen que delimitar ustedes al igual que los demás aspectos.
Porque se está inventando.
Está tomando como idea.
La venta.
Debe ser algo químico.
Debe ser algo biológico.
Ahora sí.
Haremos la siguiente fase.
Ya.
Ahora vamos a conocer.
Lo que son merges.
Que son los merges.
¿Alguien quería hablar?
Ya voy a entrar.
Listo.
Y lo ejecutan directamente.
Vamos a ver qué me da.
Ya está ya me enviado.
¿Qué pasó?
Bueno, una pregunta.
Esa.
Es el nodo de LLM Chain.
¿Cuál es la diferencia?
De colocar ahí una IA.
Y colocarlo eso.
Y colocar un agente.
Ya.
Bueno, la diferencia es que cuando trabajamos con LLM.
Este nodo se puede eliminar.
Y puedo meter otro tipo de.
O puedo conjugarlo más agentes.
Ahorita cuando trabajamos con IA.
Este ahorita que estoy ahora manejándolo.
Es como si fuera un modelo bien básico.
Que no se puede considerar que fuera un agente.
Ahora si esto lo elimino.
Lo puedo añadir digamos agentes más avanzados.
Ya.
Esa es la única diferencia.
Cuando utilices un blaze.
El blaze es como un canal.
Por eso me dice Chain.
El LLM.
Es un canal.
Ahí lo puedo añadir más modelos.
Aquí otro.
Ahí es donde trabajan con agentes.
Eso pueden hacer ustedes.
Igual lo voy a tratar de hacer en la siguiente clase.
Ya. No hay problema.
Pero ese es el trabajo.
Hay otro.
Por ejemplo acá.
Si se entra en la AI.
Váyanse directamente.
Ah.
Aquí.
Sumerization.
Y aquí otro.
Vamos a irnos acá.
Aquí dice por ejemplo.
Language models.
Se van directamente a lo que son.
Todos los modelos que puede soportar este LLM.
Todos estos trabajos.
Son lenguajes o modelos.
Por ese caso.
Estos lenguajes.
Modelos de lenguaje.
Netamente son gratuitos.
Cuando esto yo ya lo trabajo en base.
A.
Agentes.
Y es lo que habíamos visto acá.
Que tiene opciones para cambiarnos.
Ahorita si hago que esto clique.
Esto para mí es un lenguaje.
El chat básico.
Pero cuando ya le digo estoy a esos modelos de agente.
Es la única diferencia.
Unos gratuitos y otros.
Estos son los que han visto ahorita.
Todos es gratuito.
Pero obviamente tienen que tener su cuenta.
Y tienen que comprarse aunque dos dólares o cinco dólares.
Porque los pide si o si para funcionar.
Esa parte.
Eso más que todo.
Hagan pruebas chicos.
Hagan pruebas.
Creense.
Y van a ver.
Yo les recomiendo este.
Language model.
Yo les recomiendo de Antropiq.
Y la de Azure.
La de Azure les va a trabajar con bases de datos en la nube.
Ya no con bases de datos locales.
Y obviamente están los demás.
El graco también es.
Barato.
Pero que todos estos hay que comprarse.
Para que trabaja de manera gratuita.
Nada más.
Eso.
Hay también vectorizados.
Les voy a mostrar esta parte.
Aparte de estos.
Hay un supaba base.
Supaba base.
Es una base de datos SQL.
Que trabaja en la nube y es gratuito.
Hasta.
3 a 4.
Podes crearte gratuito.
Vamos a hacer esto en la siguiente clase.
Con su base de datos.
Ya no en su computador.
Si no.
En acá.
Y compós.
Supaba base trabaja con pós.
De hecho.
Ahora si.
Esta parte lo voy a eliminar.
Haremos ahora merges.
Acá van a escribir merges.
Ahí estamos.
Para que me sirve este.
Este señor.
Puede añadirme.
Monto de nodos más.
Por ejemplo. Si quieren trabajar con más nodos.
Y solamente aquí ven uno.
Si quieren trabajar con más.
Estarí que colocar.
Y pueden añadir muchas otras cosas.
Demasiadas.
Aquí pueden añadir bases de datos.
Pueden añadir archivos.
Ahora te voy a hacer.
Espero que me enganza el tiempo.
Si no la siguiente.
Vamos a continuar.
Este lo voy a dejar acá.
Y aquí.
Voy a crearme lo que es un drive.
Drive.
Voy a irme a Google Drive.
Y voy a irme directamente.
Ahora.
Yo creo que lo intenten tener la siguiente secuencia.
Ya.
La siguiente secuencia es obviamente.
Yo lo estoy enviando.
Si se ve un documento y te ha actualizado mi prom.
Ya mejorado.
Ya me da ahora.
Laptops.
Todo esos aspectos.
Pero ahora esto para un cliente.
Imagínense.
Pero el cual es el punto.
Yo no le puedo enviar.
Si yo tengo más de 2.000 artículos.
O productos.
Yo no le puedo enviar todo acá.
Imagínense.
Que va a tener que leer.
Y le va a ser bien aburrido al cliente.
Y no tengo que dar.
Entonces un catálogo.
El catálogo se envía por PDF.
Por Excel.
No sé.
Como ustedes lo vean necesario.
Pero siempre lo más adecuado.
A nivel negocio.
Siempre se enviar de manera concreta.
Directa.
Y lo que más.
Se abulicioso de nuestro negocio.
Pero lo demás no me interesa.
Lo demás es más mi producto.
Entonces eso por si acaso.
En su proyecto.
Que se pasa a ver.
El proyecto que tienen que verme.
En el documento que tienen que seguir.
Como base principal de APA.
No me pueden generar acá.
Digamos.
Productos.
Se ve feo.
Más que feo.
Entonces anteriormente.
Ya tenían aquí cargado.
Su documento.
Yo le he cargado acá.
Ya.
Como ya lo han cargado acá.
Vamos a los siguientes.
Catálogos.
Van a compartir.
Y van a colocar.
En tipo.
Cualquier usar que tenga el vínculo.
Y ahí lo van a dejar.
Como lector.
Y copian su vínculo.
Listo.
Ese vínculo.
No se olviden.
No se olviden de ese vínculo.
Traten de hacerlo acá.
En un blog de notas.
Y siempre guardense.
Lo más importante.
Es para mi.
Mi enlace.
Este enlace.
Del PDF que estoy enviando.
Netamente.
Mi interés es solamente este.
Este es el código de acceso.
Y el que va.
Y el que es mi código general.
Lo demás es.
Links nomas.
Es lo que me interesa.
Una vez que genero esa parte.
Voy a hacer lo siguiente.
Perdón.
Voy a decir.
Entonces, qué quiero yo.
El cliente.
Me está.
Tengo que cambiar un PDF.
Yo no tengo que hablar con él.
Yo no tengo que.
Hablar.
Modificar el PDF.
Por eso hay un montón de aspectos.
Dice.
A mí me interesa.
Que se descargue.
Es.
Directamente.
Algo.
Automáticamente.
Se está añadiendo.
Pero yo lo voy a eliminar.
Esto no me interesa.
Porque esto tiene que ir antes del modelo.
Perdón.
Porque voy a añadir eso.
Listo.
Pero a ver. Entraremos a la siguiente lógica.
Está.
Llenando el cliente.
Me está enviando.
Aquí está craneando la ida.
Como responderle.
Va a venir acá.
Se dan cuenta que.
Este.
Está solo.
No.
No sabe a quién poder conectarse.
Para entrar en.
En trabajo.
Que hago.
Donde ya tengo que cranear.
Dice.
No.
Con este punto.
Con este.
No se sabe.
Lo más lógico sería que lo enlace con este.
Ahí.
Listo.
Porque la ida va a ser.
Como me está enviando.
Estoy enviando el dato.
También.
Tengo que leer.
Me está enviando el cliente.
Para que yo pueda hacer ese proceso.
No sé.
En la lógica.
Voy a hacer en base a lo siguiente.
Voy a hacer doble que directamente a mi.
Drive.
Y le tengo que dar una credencia.
Una nueva credencia.
Y esa credencial.
Que le tienen que dar.
Es la misma.
La misma.
Que le han dado.
A su correo.
La misma.
Voy a volver a enchar.
No es acá.
En.
Google Cloud.
Cuando hemos hecho Google Cloud.
¿Se acuerdan que hemos habilitado
también la parte de Drive?
La hecho.
Tienen que ver esto más.
Entonces.
Ya está anexado.
No es necesario.
Vienen acá.
Van a verificar.
Van a irse a piz y servicios habilitados.
Hacen click ahí.
Y directamente debería de verse.
Ese aspecto.
Ahí.
Ya habilitado.
Aquí está.
Está habilitado Google Drive.
Está activado.
Y fíjense cuántos.
La tengo en ciudad.
Cuántas solicitudes he generado.
Y ya está.
Y pueden habilitar más.
También está habilitado Google Sheet.
Está habilitado los tres.
Eso verifiquen.
Ya.
Ahora si no está.
Ya saben.
Vienen a habilitar servicios.
Y ahí van a colocar Google Drive.
Y ahí les van a habitar.
Y le van a activar.
Nada más.
Si es que no lo tienen.
Pero ahí lo vamos a echar anteriormente en Google Cloud.
Ya.
Ahí lo voy a dar s tow la memoria.
Las Brasil me han
de ver en Google.
ya no me compió esta
no voy a hacer y la piquilla la clave yo lo tengo a ver
ya entonces acá google drive account creo que esto es lo que me creen me hecho la credencial
pero voy a ver si está bien hace increíble y ahí está ven es la misma a voy a pegarle mi blog
aquí está credencial y me está mi clave secreta y mi id pero en este caso vos es de mí
ven esa está lo mismo y aquí está mi lo mismo que acá nada más estoy copiando y mi clave secreta
lo copia y hasta de mí conectado lo colocan caby hasta cautela con conector los van a decir nada
más la dan y es el contador y listo si es que les pide
y una vez que se han conectado en este caso chicos tienen que aquí trabajar en lo siguiente
en las demás operaciones bien aquí siempre se van a elegir dolan porque tenés que descargar
a dolan algunas vas a ir copi por defecto otros van a elegir dolan y aquí en sus ors van a elegir
siempre file o folder ya esto me indica en qué posición está pero en este caso file voy a dejar
por defecto ya cuando hagan eso aquí automáticamente los va a detectar qué archivos hay mira acá ya me
apareció catálogo laptops 20 26 listó entramos ahí y hasta conectar
eso ya lo pueden ejecutar lo ejecuta
y directamente ya está ahora esta parte base de su siguiente captura de ustedes
y este de ira es un código binario el de ira que me aparece ahí necesariamente trabaja con
binarios ahorita os voy a explicar por qué trabaja con binarios voy a colocar acá
esto captura número cinco voy a colocar y que sea conexión a dry
dry
listo voy a hacer lo siguiente ahora que fíjense esto
me morí sens no me molestan sensuéndose ven que si es y le sale de ira
aquí dice binario si se dan cuenta voy a ir más que más es eso a ceebol es eso
jason es eso pero yo vivimos como binario lo voy a cerrar si se dan cuenta ya se ha conectado
paralelamente el march me voy a ir ahí y voy a hacer lo siguiente dentro de march ahí tienen que
trabajar de manera un poquito más específica ya porque el mesh base en muchas cositas que
la larga quizás no si no hago bien no se va a concretar ya estamos metiendo dos entradas no
vea dos inputs apente dice aquí voy a hacer combina vamos a combinar acá si o si vamos a
combinar porque combina porque estamos combinando ambos aspectos de mi sistema ya una vez que
estén combinando ahí aquí que dice felt a más no es tan necesario esto a no ser que dice
ahí lo dejan haber march en faz posición lo voy a dejar como por defecto y entonces lo ejecutan
si es posible vamos a ver si aquí dice chine te deslelas pero el son más allá entran caban a colocar
posición ya
ahí lo dejan en posición a los ejecutor y hasta posición lo van a dejar porque otro va a
combinar y no nos conviene que combine la y se va a buguear y ahí lo dejan y listo ya está
conectado y este ya funciona pero acá digamos que bueno se doble clica ahí está ya está viniendo
la combinación ahora si podemos ejecutar voy a irme acá y voy a hacer lo siguiente ahora voy a venir acá
y este ya me ha enviado voy a irme a mi
gmail
voy a actuar y solo
ya me llega
y fíjense me da todo
pero no me ha enviado todavía la que me envió a lo sobre todo información detallada
vamos a ver esa parte de actualizar de nuevo vamos a ver vamos a ver algunos puntos ahorita
a ver ya no me enviado vamos a lo siguiente vamos a ejecutar el prompt
o vamos a ejecutarlo de nuevo porque aquí está ejecutándose solamente esta parte
voy a revisar que más me faltaría posiciones ad option ah eso que me falta
aquí donde dice send me shesh
para el sabajo no estoy recibiendo esto de acá estoy recibiendo un código binario
vamos a añadir ad option y voy a irme a touchments ya adentro y en attachments voy a añadirle
ad attachment y lo voy a dejar si por defecto de ira porque este de ira es este se dan cuenta son
datos binarios ahora si voy a ejecutar
esperemos porque está craneando ahí estoy en el final de la vida más
y ahí es para eso
listo ya me enviado ahora se le puede ejecutar esto por muchas
hay ese ejecutado obviamente mi doble doble
ya vengo ahí
ya ya me he llegado
y ahí está dice catargo laptops
entro y justamente me he enviado el pdf que yo no quiero
ya eso es todo en esta parte si te chicos me van a enviar su screen porque es la salida que yo
requiero para sus evaluaciones ya y eso va a ser la última captura de la clase de hoy
captura número 6 resulta
captura 6
viste eso
yo en la tarea de este 7 me van a añadir y el su pdf más ya se me van a anexar a parte
del documento que me van a enviar con las capturas van a enviar su su catalogue más eso lo voy a hacer
lo voy a crear ahorita con los con los requerimientos de la tarea de hoy ya así que no se preocupa para
tarea de hoy nos voy a dar hasta la siguiente semana más y a partir de la siguiente semana
ya voy a vamos a trabajar de manera línea ya se si yo hago ustedes hacen y me envían hasta
media noche ya que vamos a tener ya clases dentro de seis clases la siguiente día va a ser casi
tocando rápidamente las cosas esa parte
listo chicos en el último último captura me van a enviar todo esto ya eso más eso nos
haremos próximos no piensas y esto me van a enviar por si acaso toda su pantalla es donde diga hora
y fecha ya para verificar yo esa cosa captura número 7 creo que 7 7 captura 7
listo hagan el esfuerzo de comprarse de psix y no es más barato que opiné
no 20 pesos al costado y se va a servir bastante
ya listo no se van a salir voy a tomar lista
ahora la clase correspondiente de hoy ya demano ratito
listo esto tengo que subir a la embajada así que no sé si es el
muchisco cruz voy a sacar tres primero
como hay lento mi interno se por cómo está bien lenta
ya lista voy a venir acá y vamos a compartir esto también
y ahora lo traeré a cojoto sus asistencias
y última esto
esto y por último
sus asistencias a ver si ya voy a dejar de compartir y voy a ver sus asistencias
y también un roto
cuantos no se dejo hoy están 15
ya mil disculpas por por su fereado pero si no nos vamos a largar nada
y no es bueno como sabés correspondientes listo estos chicos ahí están todos
todo así esto voy a dejar de compartir no se olviden los que acaban de ingresar
los voy a volver a mostrar la fecha y terminamos bien bien fecha por por plataforma ya para que no
se olvide pues de caso